Hi, Jacob.
Hello.
Good morning, how are you?
I'm doing well, how are you?
Doing good. Is it just me or your video is missing?
It's not you, it's me. I don't know what's going on.
Okay, I thought it's something going on with Twitter. It's just white. All I can see.
My gosh.
Yeah, it's just telling me that I'm connecting, so I don't know what.
Okay, gotcha. We'll probably give that a few seconds and hopefully it works. How are you so far?
Not too bad?
Oh, not too bad, gotcha. Yeah, I'm just here to have this service call and I'm supposed to be with someone. However, I got a bit of an emergency this morning, so I'm meeting you instead. So, all right, let me just go ahead and share my screen.
Okay.
Unfortunately, I'm not going to be able to see anything because I don't know what's going on. I'm going to try to shut down teams and rejoin. Yeah, I'll be back in a moment.
Ohh.
Do you want to?
Sure, rejoin. That's okay.
No problem. Take your time.
And you're back.
Okay, how about now? Let's see.
I can see you now.
All right, there we go. That was that was fun.
Better, Okay.
All you know, teens.
It happens.
Yep.
Alright, can you see my screen?
I sure can.
Okay, perfect. So we're just doing our monthly business review for the month of April to just talk about.
Mm.
anything that has changed and of course checks performance. So before we go ahead and move on, I just wanted to let you know that even though Groch is not here now, he definitely didn't leave IT by Design. So he's still with us. I know that I think you and checked.
was able to talk about it, but Rodge has taken a more senior role currently. Happy for him. But now we are going to introduce to you a new team lead for co-manage. So he was supposed to be here, to be honest, but unfortunately he got into a motorcycle accident.
OK.
Yeah.
Not good. Yeah, but he's okay now at the hospital resting. But he should be here next week so that you and him can be able to have a catch up. So he's been in the industry for 12 years now. So doing incident management, technical.
Ohh.
Yeah.
and everything along the lines of the MSP community. So he's very much aware of how things are going. Recently sorted, but still slowly acclimating to everything. So yeah.
Mhm.
Yep, OK.
Soon, you'll meet him, but moving on, you'll have to deal with me, Jacob, unfortunately. Yeah, thank you.
I don't know of the check.
Gotcha. So same agenda, check in highlights, action tracker, performance, KPI, and user CSAT, way forward and recap these are our agenda for today. So how are things? How are you? How is everything? And Jack, of course.
Yeah.
Me, I'm good. As I'm sure you saw in the emails, Steve is no longer with Easy IT, so I'm now the client services super, or I'm the manager, no longer a supervisor. So I'm still currently
Mhm.
Congrats, son.
overseeing the plot of engineers that Jack is a part of. So for the time being, I'm still supervisor for him.
Mhm.
That may change. We are looking at hiring a new supervisor, but we'll discuss that down the road when we get there. So no big deal, but yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Gotcha. Appreciate it. And also just wanted to let you know, I'm not sure if you're part of the email, but Lisa did renew with us already for the 7%. So glad for that. I already had an annual conversation or annual appraisal for a project as well. So that should be taken care of.
Mhm.
Okay.
All right, perfect. Highlights, so Derek has been one of, has been on a perfect attendance week for the month of April, no late absences. He's just on top of it. And I think for the past quarter, we just don't have any issues with him at all. It's not like I threaten him, but we just talk of it.
Yeah.
Right.
Just talk about it, and he's just here earlier than I do, so just a very, very good thing. Next is, Derek's impressive CSAT score is driven by workflow discipline and quality of work provided, which we're going to see at a later date. I did provide the feedback that we discussed last QBR about the quality.
Mhm.
With.
Of his tickets, so the TFA was able to get that sorted out, you know, slowly, but had to progress within it.
Mhm.
Mm-hmm.
All right, any questions so far?
No.
All right, action tracker. So we did send it out, the feedback for April. Not sure if you've seen it. If not, then I can just retrigger that.
Ice.
Thought I responded to it.
Oh, you did? Yeah, if you did, then that's fine.
I think I did.
Okay, gotcha. I'll just look up, if not, then I'll just send you an email. Easy.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, that sounds good.
All right, perfect. Performance analysis. So we know our best practices. Utilization trend and analysis. So overall utilization, of course, it's 100%. That means that he's tracking all of his time, non-billable or billable. But overall, billable utilization average is 85%.
Mhm.
exceeding our target for him, which is 80%. Week one and four is the highest billable week for him, driven by a lighter internal meeting load. And I'm sorry if I'm pulling him out sometimes that I gotta talk to him. But yeah, it's just me and his previous, his current team lead that had that catch up.
Mm.
That's OK.
like a one-on-one.
Moving forward, Marky, Marky is his name, the new team lead. He'll be able to reach out to, I didn't want to just add him to the group chat before I actually introduced him to you, so I didn't add him yet.
Yeah.
Sure.
Inside, you know, the admin person spikes in weeks two, three, and 5th, which are 17% lunch, learning, and study time. And I hope that he is putting in like the definition of what study time means and what he's trying to train and study for, not a chronic.
Mhm.
billable drift and as opposed to freak 4 shows the optimal ballot lowest admin time and second highest billable full hours locked.
Any questions?
Nope.
numbers looks the same from your end.
Let me check.
Okay.
Let's see.
So we consider utilization a little bit different.
Okay.
So utilization would be time spent working tickets, so would be his total time minus admin time.
Tickets.
Yes.
would be his utilization and then billable would be what of that utilization was billable. So if we take a look at...
Mm.
Is for April.
Okay.
Able to...
So...
He had an average of 89 percent.
So that would...
Match, if you look at the admin time, it would average out and then his billable was 85.
Mhm.
Okay.
Average for the month.
Gotcha, understood. Um, Steve has...
So those are well above what our.
Targets are.
Yeah, so he's doing great.
Gotcha. Perfect. That's good to hear though. I was given an access to some of your KPI, but it's just a view access that Steve has given me. So there was no filter of understanding what is the month where it was. I was seeing past.
Mhm.
six months or quarterly date. So is there a way for me to see that monthly or even not me marquee moving forward so we can actually trace and get it?
This is.
So let's see. So you guys are getting information from BrightGauge, I believe.
Mhm.
Yes.
So let me pull up his dashboard and see what...
K.
Just to give you an idea of what was shared, this was it.
Yeah, so that looks right.
Yeah.
Mmh.
It's just a matter of, you know, filtering it out for that one, what's going on. I was like, uh, I don't know how to actually check this out.
Right.
Yeah, so.
I need to go through and clean this up because it's a bit of a mess. And some of the information is a little redundant and doesn't make sense. So that's kind of part of my task, like things that I want to get accomplished.
PH.
Mmhmm.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Previous month, have a previous month.
No, see, that's the thing is we don't, we have all this information, but none of it is previous month. So...
I gotcha.
Yeah, don't sweat. That's okay, 'cause we'll be fine. I can wait.
Yeah, if you pull that sheet back up for me real quick, I want to see you at the top of it.
Sure.
This one.
Okay.
So it doesn't seem to show you.
This, why not?
So I'm not sure if this was just downloaded, so it's not a live dashboard.
No, that's a just a like a snapshot of the report of at that time, so...
Exactly.
Yeah, I'll have to figure that out and see what we can do to make it a little bit cleaner for you.
Mmh.
Mm-hmm.
So I'm assuming I'm going to have to set up something so I can get you guys this every week now.
Mhm.
So, let me, let me work on that today.
Sure, that's okay. For, so do you don't think that we can have like a view visibility for the dashboard itself?
No, so...
Unfortunately, no, because of...
Fair.
ConnectWise and the way they have pushed single sign-on.
Okay, so you need credentials. Gotcha.
Yeah, you'd have to have an account within our tenant and our security team won't allow that.
Mhm.
I know, gotcha, understood.
Yeah, it's unfortunate.
Okay, end of report it is. So we'll just wait for that report weekly so that we can track it and, you know, give you a better number because doing business review and giving a different number from what you're seeing doesn't really make sense. So I wanted to make sure that the numbers are accurate. So we're actually looking at
Yeah.
The same thing.
Yeah, so the numbers are accurate of what you're seeing. So like that second section where it says,
Mhm.
Average, oops, this one.
Well, no, so if you look at our data.
Overall.
Oh, the previous, okay. Let me just go back to that, this one.
Yeah, so on that, that first one that says utilization all texts.
Mhm.
So you can see that the weak utilization, 88.3%, that is the...
Total time minus ADMIN.
Okay.
divided by total time. So basically, he has 8 hours on his time sheet because he has whatever he tracked from tickets plus admin equals 8 hours. You take whatever the time is without the admin, divide that by 8 to 88.3. So that's utilization.
Mm.
Okay. And then for last week, this is 87, including the total billable hours and utilize hours. Gotcha. Okay.
Mhm.
Correct.
to allow it.
So I wonder if...
Is there a way for me to do something like this?
Mm.
Export.
Oh, interesting. Let me try this really quick while we're here. If you want to continue going on, I'm going to try exporting some data here, because if this is more helpful, then I can send you this instead.
Sure.
Yeah, okay.
Mhm.
Sure, okay.
That's completely fine.
Okay.
All right. Same with the ticket closure trend and analysis that we've had. So overall, he did work under a total of 274 tickets and closed out to 134 out of those. Week one was the highest recorded weekly rate at 96%, where all 36 tickets in the queue were
all cleared that he touched. Week four was the strong of full week performance at 88, combining high volume and efficient closure. So week 3 maintained 81%, but April 20 was this just standout single day. So 23 tickets worked and 22 closed, the highest single day throughput recorded.
So your resolution rate was a bit on a dip side on the last week, which is 78% on every single working day. I had a coaching time with him. It's not because of failing below that floor. It's just that
the consistency that he had as much as the volume is really low at that time.
Mhm.
Yep.
So yeah, so average closure all through and through is 85% for April.
Okay.
All right, perfect. So for CSAT, we have a total of CSAT responses of 18, which is a good thing. Out of 18, he had like 17 responses that has given him 10 as a score, which is a 94% CSAT, which is same with our target.
However, for their response rate, we are targeting 30% of that, which he did achieve. So only one ticket pulled the score below 10, but it's still 8. So not really something that I worry about. But we wanted to, of course, aim for a score of 10 overall.
Okay.
Other than that, no CSID scores were recorded.
All right, so way forward, we wanted to shift focus from tickets work to ticket close and aging reduction. So before with other engineers, what I did was I also tracked the carried over from the previous month or the previous week to the week following for that, so that we wanted to make sure that if there are a lot of carried
carry over from the past week so we can actually understand the efficiency of the engineer through and through. So I'll start showing you that next week. Well, next month, not next week, it's just a monthly. So we do it next month so that we understand his efficiency more.
Mhm.
This is.
And again, set an admin and training guardrail target of less than 8% weekly. So it will lower down that 17% that we had this month. And of course, we had that ITBD holiday Memorial Day on the 25th. So just wanted to know if you need him.
to come in and work at the time.
No, we're off that day, so he's good to have that day off.
Cool, I'll make sure that we do let the team know also. So I'll let him know that he's out on the 25th. He'll be happy. And also, I think I was told briefly by him that he has a, he's about to file a.
Yeah, I'm sure.
the PTO, I think on June 1st and 2nd, if I'm not mistaken, but they'll send you that email so you can approve it forward. So, still a month away, anyway.
Okay.
Yep.
Gotcha. Yeah, and on the next meeting that we have, Jacob, you're going to meet our TTL so that we can give him necessary access from what you are showing me. So we can probably add him to that distro list for that report.
Okay.
Okay, so I just sent you an email with two attachments.
Let me check that out.
So the first one is the usual one that I send weekly with the ticket report, but the PDF is the one I want you to open.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Okay.
Opener.
Oops.
I'll just download it first.
Okay. Oh, this looks nice. Let me just share my screen.
Yeah.
Yep.
Oh.
So this should hopefully be easier to read.
Then the brake gauge.
Okay.
So this is a snapshot of Derek, as you can see in the top left, for the entire month of March, or sorry, April.
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
So you can see.
Okay.
So since this is just a PDF, you're not going to be able to like change these settings or anything, but you can see the average utilization at the top, 91.65%, with an average billable of 85.08%.
91.
Yeah, true.
Mhm.
And then below that, down to the bottom part on the left, you can see the breakdown daily.
Mmh.
So each day you can see what those different percentages are and how they fluctuate. So then you have on the right.
Billable.
Ooh.
The.
Those top three don't really matter much for Jack because he's always remote.
Mhm.
And he always submits his PTO in advance because he's...
He's planning. And then the next three boxes are...
just a breakdown of showing the different days and how the texts are, allows us to find trends if someone's like continually slacking on a specific day, we can find out what's going on. And then just a...
Utilization.
Mhm.
a nice line graph of those different utilizations over time.
Gotcha. Wow, this is, yeah, way better. Yeah, so this is what I wanted to probably get. If you can send this every, I don't know, Friday, maybe.
Okay.
So it may be better if I send it.
Partner.
What if I send it on Wednesday with the same ticket report for the previous week? Is that okay?
Yeah, that's okay. That's fine.
Okay, so we'll just, yeah, I'll send both at the same time and I'll just grab a snapshot of the previous week. And then if you want to have a full month when we're doing the...
Mmh.
Do you want to have a full month worth of data at once like this? We can always, you can always ask for it.
Okay.
The.
Yeah, definitely. So I just wanted to track it like for the TTLL's perspective so that they can actually see what's happening, if there is any trend alongside that, so that they can work with bid check locally. So.
Mhm.
Right.
Yeah, so if you look at the average billable day, you can always see Wednesday is going to be his lowest day.
Mhm.
Is there a reason for that?
And there is. We have our, well, it's changed now. So we used to have a weekly all hands meeting every Wednesday.
Mhm.
Oh, okay. How many hours? Two?
It's one.
One hour, gotcha.
However, that's no longer weekly. It's going to be once a month. So hopefully that number will be more closer to the regular other day. But also previously, whilst also having that one hour.
Better.
All hands meeting right after that we had our 30 minute pod meeting. So he had an hour and a half straight of meetings that aren't billable. So.
Ohh.
Back to back, I got to.
Yeah. So it always costs his Wednesday to look lower. So yeah. So they're just not billables. That's why you see the billables lower. But when you look at the utilization next to it, he's very close.
Meetings.
Gotcha.
Mhm.
Yeah, very close. I gotcha. Great. I love this PDF. I love this report, Jacob. So this would help me out a lot. So yeah, I'll wait for this.
So...
Yep. Okay.
Yeah, so it doesn't provide any of the end user CSATs right now.
Mhm, mhm.
So I'm not sure how important that is.
Um, I think he does fill it out anyway. I usually just ask him to send me those, so...
Okay, because he has access, he should have access to the BrightGauge dashboard himself.
Yeah.
Mmh.
And he can get that information from there.
Sure. I usually for the CSAT, I just get it month end so that I have all the compilation of the CSAT that he accrued over over that month. So I'm pretty cool with that. Unless of course there is a bad CSAT review that I got to I got to work with him about.
Yep.
Okay.
Sure.
All right, perfect. Thank you very much. Appreciate this so much. How about, how about the quality now, Jacob? Did it improve since last time we talked?
I'm going to be real with you, I haven't had a lot of time to dig into it. Things have changed. Things have been kind of wild around here, so I've been quite busy. So hopefully next month I'll have a better understanding of what that looks like.
This.
Yeah.
I know.
Anderson.
Sure, I gotcha. No rush. I just wanted to make sure that you're progressing and just in case he needs further help, which he rarely really needs help. He's very self-sufficient, to be honest with you. But again, those are the things, or some of the things that he missed because he's just doing this on a daily basis, right?
Yep.
Yeah.
I know.
which is why we're here for. But yeah, no rush on your side of the fence. I know there's a lot of moving pieces. Left, right and center. Tell me about it. But yeah, I'll meet you next time and I'll make sure that we progress and I'll have this report soon. So thank you so much. Appreciate it. Any questions?
Mhm.
Yep.
Yeah, you're welcome. Nope, I don't have any.
So far.
Okay, I know you're bestie, so I'll get you back to it. Thank you very much for attending. Have a good day.
Yeah, thank you. See ya.
Bye-bye.